The king is dead the door remains
shut until we finish our business
it is treason at the least
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is my
house of the dragon video all about the green
council if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes but
episode 9 is called the green council it's a
reference to the separate small council that
alicent's greens create when they attend a coup
of Swords to execute with alicent believes to be
viserys's dying wishes that her son with him aegon
II be named the next king before this you simply
have the small council like the small council
is meant to support the king it's meant to be
relatively impartial just supporting whatever
his wishes are but you have this whole idea the
divided allegiance in the red keep because of
what's happened with Team Green and team black
team alicent versus team rhaenyra even though
alicent is not trying to put herself on the
Iron Throne you have this question over what
people believe viserys's wishes to actually be
like did he actually want aegon II to become king
or should they uphold viserys's wishes that they
heard before this that rhaenyra should become the
next queen as you would expect most people on the
small council will spend a long time arguing
debating about the matter but clearly that is
not what happens clearly Otto Hightower tries to
move as quickly as possible to prevent anybody
that supports rhaenyra from doing anything about
them naming aegon II the next king but you have to
remember what's happened in the last six years
since the events of the previous episode when
alicent attacked rhaenyra with the Valyrian dagger
rhaenyra married daemon targaryen and then took
the family back to Dragonstone she'd already been
on Dragonstone for a while since then away from
court the longer she's away from Court the less
influence she has with her father and with a small
council itself which is already kind of a problem
now another six years have gone by even though
she's had a couple more children with Daemon like
a couple things have happened in the six years but
in that time a couple other small council members
have been rotated so the small council has changed
in the last six years and since the incident
with the Valyrian dagger things cooled between
alicent and rhaenyra and they talked even less
like where Nira became even less involved with
what was happening at court with her father in the
small council they talked a little bit about that
during the reunion at the beginning of last week's
episode they hadn't seen each other in so long
like us look at all the changes you made around
the red keep it looks like you got riddle out of
the Targaryen hair and now the red keep looks more
like the great sept so before the small council
transforms into the green council officially so
to speak most of them had already been firmly Team
Green and the whole idea is that before the dance
of the Dragons had gotten started before viserys's
death even though alicent had been sitting in his
place at the head of the small council they'd at
least try to attempt for them to be impartial with
them serving everyone's interests most of them had
assumed previously that renero would become Queen
on viserys's death and her son jacaris will become
the heir apparent but with the ending of episode 7
visares hopped up on milk of the poppy mistakenly
thinking he was talking to rhaenyra he spoke to
alicent about the remainder of aegon's Prophecy of
the prince who was promised A Song of Ice and Fire
the long night how he firmly believed the prophecy
was true and even though alicent thought it was
all gibberish because she'd never heard aegon's
prophecy before she didn't know about the dagger
viserys kept repeating the name aegon and Future
King separately and he was referring to aegon the
first Targaryen but because he only said aegon he
didn't say aegon the first or aegon the conqueror
she just picked that out because there's son was
also named aegon and separately when he said all
those things about him being King then separately
about his future line and then separately about
uniting the realm like it was all kind of broken
up as different phrases how terrible things would
happen unless this all came to pass her brain
filled in all the wrong gaps and just assumed that
he meant something terrible would happen unless
aegon II became king and one of her big things is
that she's got this Ned Stark level of belief in
doing your duty even if you don't like what you're
doing doing what powerful people like the king the
people in your family ask of you like she'd always
done what her father told her to do even if she
didn't like it so at this moment even though she
just got done telling rhaenyra that she would
make a fine Queen she believes viserys's wishes
must be upheld even though that was all based on
a mistake so viserys dies she tells the regular
small council about everything that happened this
conversation with him because none of them were
there nobody can say anything different like they
just take what she says word for word it seems
like it's still dark like it's the wee hours of
the morning right after they learn of his death
and even though it's a mistake after she tells
them about his wishes clearly what you can see
is that chaos ensues you'd expect nothing less
from a game of thrones show and remember the
current small council even though some of them
are firmly Team Green like Otto Hightower here are
supposed to be relatively impartial when it comes
to favoring alicent or verniera they just merely
execute the will of the king like the laws that
have already been laid out so even if they don't
like rhaenyra they still at least have to uphold
the king's wishes but what alicent says basically
throws everything into complete chaos now remember
this before they pull off a coup the current
small council as you're seeing sitting here is
Otto Hightower hand of the king obviously firmly
Team Green he's the one that's kind of pulling the
strings kind of pushing alicent around the board
here playing that game of chess playing The Game
of Thrones the other important thing you'll notice
here is that Criston Cole is standing at her other
shoulder because he's so firmly team alicent
this whole time he's been a regular member of the
kingsguard but he's also been part of her personal
detail like her personal member of the kingsguard
as she said previously he's supposed to uphold
her wishes over the wishes of the king earlier
when she demanded he attacked young lucerus he
paused for just a second because he's like wait a
minute you want me to cut out this young boy's eye
normally he'd be expected to do whatever alicent
told him to do the problem is is that before
this like going back to the time of aegon the
Conqueror the creation of the kingsguard none of
the kingsguard had ever been asked to do something
against the wishes of the king so that's why he
pauses for a second like no Queen thus far has
asked us to defy the wishes of the king then you
have Tylen Lannister of House Lannister who has
long since been master of ships already hasn't
like rhaenyra that much because a long time
ago she rejected his brother when they proposed a
marriage linking the future of house Lannisters as
the Future King consort even though the Lannisters
are already very powerful very rich right now had
they become king consort they would have been even
more powerful Jasper Wylde has been the master of
laws for the past six years at least he's also
been an alicent supporter over rhaenyra in all
that time larys strong hasn't officially been
on the small council but he's been unofficially
alicent's master of whispers since they were
younger like going way back far longer than most
of the current small council have been sitting on
the council and the current grand maester Orwell
has been sitting on the small council for the past
six years succeeding Mellos who he had previously
supported when he was serving King viserys so
orwyle has been serving in the red keep for a
long time then there's old Lord beesbury Lord
dear me he's been master of coin ever since King
joharis has reigned long before viserys became
king so he's been on the small council probably
longer than Otto Hightower because Otto Hightower
was also J Harris's final hand of the king but he
only served jaharis for a little while before
his death before the transition to King viserys
and right now here in westerling has been Lord
commander of the kingsguard for a long time so
you remember back when alicent asked Criston
Cole to cut out luceris's eye hair westerling
was like wait a minute what are you doing here
buddy so it seems like Harold westerling is at
least trying to be impartial in all this but
as you see alicent Hightower tells her father
Otto Hightower what happened with the thesaurus
about his wishes Otto hightower's gears start
moving in his head he tries to pull up this
quick coup and it throws a small council into
complete chaos and it seems like Lord beesbury
is screaming about treason because he opposes
them actually pulling off a coup like no no we
can't name aegon the second king just because
you heard something and viserys's dying wishes
we need to talk about this for a little while but
Otto Hightower doesn't want to have anything to
do with that and it seems like Criston Cole firmly
Team Green cuts his head off like he pulls his
sword on him so it seems like everybody that was
sitting on the small council who wasn't already
firmly Team Green at the site of Lord beesbury
losing his head immediately switched their
allegiance to Team Green in either Criston Cole
winds up killing Harold westerling in the ensuing
coup but it seems like the Kingsguard allegiance
is divided itself like the kingsguard fights
other kingsguard so essentially Criston Cole
replaces Harold Westerling as the lord commander
kingsguard of the green council and also I believe
that Thailand Lannister winds up replacing the
now dead Lord beesberry as the new master of
coin Lannister's rich as gold it makes sense that
they would be master of coin at some point but
basically anyone one who's been impartial before
this is now either dead gone like they take off or
they flip their allegiance to the greens thus the
small council becomes the green council the title
of the episode the whole reason why they call them
the greens is because of alicent's green gown that
she's been known for wearing like she's wearing
different types of gowns but they've all been
green ever since she was younger since renira's
wedding to laner Valerian the reason why alicent
chose green is because green is the color of
the flame of the historical house Hightower
that they light when they go to war so the whole
idea is that at that moment she was declaring war
on rhaenyra so to speak even though the actual
Targaryen Civil War the dance of the Dragons does
it really start till this particular episode till
the naming of the green council and then trying to
put aegon II On The Iron Throne that's like the
official beginning of the dance of the Dragons
the other cool Easter egg the cool connection
with the events later in the timeline on the
Game of Thrones series is that Margaery Tyrell is
alicent's descendant through her cousin through
alicent's cousin currently during the events of
this series the Tyrells still rule over the reach
that star started during aegon's conquest or after
aegon's conquest they took control of the reach
after aegon's conquest because House Gardner
refused to bend the knee to aegon so he killed
them and basically replaced them with the tyrells
one of the reasons why green is such an important
color to house Hightower and to alicent obviously
later is because that's tied to the history behind
house Gardener and Garth Greenhand in the reach
old town is in the reach so technically they've
been a vassal House of house Gardener this whole
time for thousands and thousands of years Garth
Greenhand historically is supposed to have been
the first High King of the first men thousands
of years before the Andals invaded so even though
when you think of the color green you mostly think
of the tyrells technically that goes back to Garth
Greenhand and house gardner but that's also why
house Hightower would have used the green flame
and lit that in the high tower during times of War
because historically they had supported the reach
in the gardeners at least until aegon's Conquest
the reason why they survived is because the high
towers and the tyrells both supported aegon so
after the conquest aegon rewarded them with much
higher positions we just have the hightowers wound
up so close to the iron throne but my full episode
9 video will post later tonight after they release
it if you have any questions about what's going on
during the episode just leave them in the comments
and I'll be sure to add them to my episode video
everyone click here for my full episode 9 video
update the link as soon as I post that and click
here for all my other house of the dragon videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!